when you do your YouTube TV show yes sir
do you do the sports thing on there I do
some sports I do pop culture I do
politics I do everything I'm politics
yes where are you I see I don't know
this part of you okay I'm a registered
independent I'm not enamored with either
candidate you have people that are in
office they don't resonate and I
understand Barack Obama said a
incredible standard because my god when
it came to giving a speech you did it
better we all know how smooth that
brother was but the bottom line is
somebody could come close do something
would you ever run for office hell no
hell no you know why you're making a lot
of money that's right right there stop
right there if if it wasn't listen I'm
I'm not going to give up let I'm on how
turn show man let me be very very candid
I'm not giving up my quality of life to
earn $400,000 a year and be stressed it
ain't happening okay so it's that simple
to me can I confess to you though I I
will I will people GNA call me crazy
obviously I have my show first take on
ESPN every weekday morning right yes
it's a debate
show I would love to be in a
presidential debate I nothing I think
you do great oh my no no I'd eat him
alive but you wouldn't do it you
wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't run for the presidency but I
debate Trump any day of the week any day
of the week name the time and place and
I'd show
up
h